شكرا جزيلا ريما بالتاكيد هذه اللحظات
التاريخيه بالنسبه لنادي الاتحاد انضمام
افضل لاعب في العالم الى صفوف نجم الفرنسي
كريم بنزيما الذي سيبدا مع الاتحاد مشواره
الجديد لاعبا للفريق
الاتحادي في المواسم الثلاثه المقبله
نشاهد الان على الهواء مباشره المؤتمر
الصحفي الخاص بتقديم كريم بنزيما في لاعبا
لناديه الاتحاد وذلك في مدينه الملك عبد
الله الرياضيه في جده
اذا الاتحاد يقدم لعبه للصحافه لعبه
الجديد نجمه الجديد كريم بنزيما نستمع
اذا كان في الترجمه للمؤتمر الصحفي ام لا
يوجد ترجمه لكن نحاول نلتقط بعض
الاجابات من النجم الفرنسي كريم بنزيما
اذا
الاتحاد يقدم كريم بنزيما للوسائل الاعلام
الان قبل تقديمه للجماهير بعد قليل في
ملعب مدينه الملك عبد الله الرياضيه في
جداء اللاعب الذي
يمثل نادي الاتحاد في السنوات الثلاث
المقبله نستمع الان الى الاجابات بنزيما
في المؤتمر الصحفي
بنزيما في وراء هذا التوقيع غايه وهدف
خلينا نتكلم عليها من الساحه داخل الملعب
وخارج الملعب
طبعا
نبحث عن التطور نبحث
عن جعل اسم المملكه
منظومه متكامله هي اكيد جزء لا يتجزا منها
لاعبين محترفين بقيمه كريم بنزيما وان شاء
الله باذن الله انه القادم افضل واجمل
باذن الله كريم
طبعا جزء لا يتجزا من نادي الاتحاد هو
جمهوره اللي هو يعتبر افضل جمهور موجود في
الدوري السعودي حضور قياسي وحتى اليوم ترى
المعلوميه حضور الجماهير اليوم في حفل
تقديم اللاعب كريم بنزيما يعتبر الاكبر في
العالم من ناحيه العدد واكيد طبعا الكريم
يعني في ضمن النقاش
تكلمنا عن جمهور الاتحاد والنجمهور الذهب
ومدرب مدرج عظيم واروح الاتحاد اللي طبعا
فيها شيء
حينما نشاهد كريم بنزيما مع الاتحاد
بالتاكيد النادي لديه طموحات كبيره تطلعات
كبيره ايش ممكن توجهون كلمه للجماهير
الحاليه طبعا اولا نشكرهم على وقفتهم
معانا ونشكر الجميع طبعا
اللي ساعدنا وعاونا في بداياتنا الحمد لله
احنا بعد اربع سنين يعني انجازاتنا الحمد
لله كان واضحه للجميع
طبعا سواء كانت بطولات او رعايات او
التعاقد مع لاعب كبير مثل كريم بنزيما
القادم اجمل وافضل وباذن الله باذن الله
نادر الاتحاد يكون دائما الاول وزي ما حدا
يقول رؤيتنا انه نادي الاتحاد يكون افضل
نادي سعودي عالمي وان شاء الله باذن الله
راح نكمل التوفيق لكم ميرسي كريم
في ملعب مع المشجعين انا طبعا
لدي شغف كبير انضم الى الجماهير
ونتشارك معهم هذه اللحظه مع كافه الجماهير
والبلد بكامله اشكر ايضا رئيس النادي
والنادي وكافه الجماهير
المتواجدين ستكون لحظه رائعه وانا سعيد
جدا شكرا لك كريم
شكرا لكم على المشاهده نتمنى لكريم بنزيما
حظا سعيدا مع نادي الاتحاد ننتقل الان الى
الملعب مع الجماهير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات